nick paul colmatage raboteux et fissures
les rues de montréal ont depuis très
longtemps mauvaise réputation mais la
ville d'y réaliser des progrès pour
améliorer l'état de la chaussée de ses
artères le pourcentage des chaussées du
réseau artériel en excellent ou en bon
état est passée de 21 à 41 % entre 2015
et 2018
on comptait 55 % d'artères dont les
chaussées étaient en très mauvais état
ou en mauvais état en 2015
ce chiffre est maintenant de 39% fait à
noter l'analyse n'inclut pas les petites
rues résidentielles pour certains
automobilistes
il n'y a pas de quoi se réjouir
maintenant ça s'améliore pas du tout
cher tout les jo pcf relief et il n'y a
aucune amélioration du tout du tout du
tout honnêtement c'est une des raisons
plus je me suis acheté un pick up
parce qu'on gagne des flat dans tout les
nids de poule avec un e shop
ils étaient négligés pendant longtemps
donc il faut vivre avec les conséquences
qui je pense qu'ils font leur possible
pour améliorer ça les artères
principales ya tellement de camionnage
des camions sont obligés de parler
artères importantes comme papineau saint
denis christophe colomb et ça paraît que
c'est vraiment là cheval s'est vraiment
détérioré la ville a beaucoup à faire
pour être à la hauteur selon ce
professeur de le ps et au lieu de faire
du préventif on est toujours en train de
dépenser 4 5 fois plus pour faire du
curatif bien après la date nécessaire à
laquelle il aurait fallu intervenir
la mairesse elle est encouragée par
l'amélioration des dernières années même
si elle reconnaît qu'il faut en faire
plus en sachant que de plus en plus de
russes sont en excellente état
moi ça me donne le goût de continuer
d'investir davantage bien qu'on fasse on
autant que dans notre budget une large
part qui est dédié
ou à la réparation et à l'aménagement
des rues le budget alloué à la réfection
de l'ensemble du réseau routier
s'élèvera à 360 millions pour 2019
la ville estime qu'il faudra encore dix
ans pour le remettre à niveau ici
valérie michaela bayne fera tout est
made à montréal